j'ouvre tout de suite notre second débat
pour une fois on est également en pleine
actualité on va analyser les enjeux des
élections de mi-mandat aux États-Unis
Joe Biden va-t-il devenir un canard
boiteux un président sans majorité
parlementaire que fera Donald Trump
d'une éventuelle victoire républicaine
avant d'entendre nos Experts le récit
des dernières heures de campagne avec
Sandra serreira
par poser Donald Trump a Miami Joe Biden
à New York on se croirait presque revenu
il y a deux ans lors du duel pour la
présidentielle américaine mais il s'agit
bien d'un scrutin de mi-mandat où les
électeurs doivent choisir un tiers des
sénateurs et leur représentant au
Congrès hier venu soutenir la gouverneur
de New York le président américain
rappelle que les fondements même du pays
sont en jeu
et l'élection la plus importante de
notre vie va se jouer pour les décennies
à venir la démocratie et littéralement
sur le bulletin de vote
en 20 ans jamais un président américain
n'est parvenu à garder la majorité aux
élections de mi-mandat en cas de
victoire républicaine les électeurs
démocrates craignent pour leurs droits
fondamentaux il y a beaucoup d'enjeux
avec ce bulletin de vote comme
l'interdiction de l'avortement le climat
et la violence des armes ce sont des
sujets très importants pour notre avenir
et notre génération c'est important
d'aller voter
selon les sondages la Chambre des
Représentants équivalents de l'Assemblée
nationale serait largement remporté par
les républicains
du côté du Sénat qui est aux États-Unis
la chambre la plus puissante au Congrès
cela devrait se jouer à un siège près de
quoi revigorer Donald Trump qui espère
une vague rouge il surf sur l'inflation
les problèmes énergétiques du pays pour
rallier les foules sans oublier son
thème de prédilection
si vous voulez la sécurité pour votre
famille la sécurité pour votre
communauté vous devez voter pour éjecter
tous les démocrates
et Donald Trump entretient un faux
suspense sur sa candidature à la
présidentielle de 2024
et maintenant pour que notre pays soit
prospère sur et glorieux je vais
probablement devoir le faire à nouveau
rester à l'écoute
40 millions d'Américains ont déjà voté
par anticipation les 200 millions
d'électeurs restants sont appelés aux
urnes demain une victoire des
républicains aura inévitablement des
conséquences sur la politique de Joe
Biden qui n'aura plus beaucoup de
leviers d'action avec des conséquences
aussi en Europe sur le climat et la
guerre en Ukraine voilà beaucoup de
questions à aborder un fil rouge et cela
revanche de Donald Trump qui se profile
à l'horizon avec ce vote demain
j'accueille Sylvie Berman bonsoir
ancienne ambassadrice de France auteur
de Madame l'ambassadeur publié aux
éditions talandiers Christine de mélo
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes professeur
de civilisation et politique américaine
à l'Université de Paris 3 Sorbonne
Nouvelle Jean-Claude Beaujour bon soirée
bienvenue à vos cas spécialiste des
États-Unis et Mathieu croissanto
évidemment est resté à mes côtés
quelques chiffres parce que on oublie
parfois que dans un scrutin américain on
vote pour beaucoup de de candidats
différents donc il y a les 435 sièges de
la Chambre de prendre en temps qui sont
à renouveler un tiers du Sénat les
gouverneurs dans 36 États et 133
référendums locaux qui sont également
organisés si je vous propose un Sylvie
Berman a peut-être une analyse un peu
générale un bilan de cette campagne
est-ce qu'on voit toujours un pays aussi
fracturé ça c'est ce qui ressort le plus
la façon la plus évidente oui c'est un
pays totalement polarisé et ça depuis
l'élection de Donald Trump ça s'est
renforcé encore et d'ailleurs on l'a vu
alors d'un côté l'engagement non
seulement de Donald Trump mais des Baby
Trump qui sont extrémistes de l'autre
côté
Barack Obama c'est beaucoup impliqué
surtout en raison des problèmes de santé
de de Joe Biden et puis alors d'un côté
c'est America First c'est-à-dire les
problèmes des Américains d'abord on en
parlera peut-être tout à l'heure avec
les conséquences sur la politique
étrangère et de l'autre côté le thème
c'est la défense de la démocratie et en
fait
aboli en juin dernier donc la question
de l'avortement exactement
de questions subsidiaires qui sont
posées aux Américains demain quand on
parle des référendums ça porte aussi
là-dessus absolument dans certains états
absolument ouais
Jean-Claude
bonjour pardon on parle beaucoup de
Donald Trump évidemment et c'est un peu
le fil rouge je le disais de ce de ce
débat est-ce que vous en analysant la
campagne vous vous dites très clairement
il a toujours la main sur le parti
républicain ou est-ce que c'est plus
compliqué que ça alors quand on a la
mention partie c'est parce qu'on veut
aller aux élections et qu'on veut gagner
des élections donc est-ce qu'il a la
main sur le parti en tout cas
aujourd'hui alors qu'il y a 5-7 ans il
était
marginalisé quand il a un peu fait un
hold-up sur le parti républicain
aujourd'hui c'est le seul à
occuper tout l'espace dynamisé le seul
de manière la plus visible parce qu'il y
a d'autres personnalités au sein du
parti républicain qui important
d'embuscade je pense à au gouverneur de
la Floride qui pourrait demain si Donald
Trump était moins visible qui pourrait
aussi être challenger donc il a oui il
anime il fait le job il est le plus
droitier possible dans sa conquête du
parti républicaine dans son assise du
parti républicain tout en sachant que de
fait ça suscite une forme de rejet y
compris dans son propre parti je ferai
remarquer que Barack Obama est venu
prêter main forte à dubaiden alors que
de l'autre côté les bouches sont très
éloignées n'ont rien à voir avec avec
Trump ça c'est la première chose et puis
la deuxième chose c'est la doctrine la
doctrine Trump n'est pas la même on a un
petit tout à l'heure n'est pas la même
que celle de Ryan ou de bouche dans les
premières années aujourd'hui on est sur
quelque chose de complètement différent
ni quel c'est quelque chose qui se
rapproche de la souveraineté avec avec
un vocabulaire un peu messianique avec
cette doctrine
elle l'a emporté de fait au sein du
parti
d'un manière d'obtenir radicaliser si
vous regardez bien Donald Trump vous dit
je vais faire le job mais on ne sait
toujours pas parce qu'il y a quand même
des gens très bien ou partir une peau
chez les républicains donc quand on vous
dit je vais faire le job mais qu'on ne
sait pas alors je vais faire le job
alors vous avez des gens qui machin oui
qui qui s'agitent c'est bien pour un
pour pour le show mais quand ton droit
mettre le bulletin de vote et qu'on se
dit mais au fond qu'est-ce qu'il va
faire est-ce que par exemple sur la
politique étrangère qu'elle sera quels
seront ces positions les Américains ont
des intérêts par exemple vous avez
entendu ma Carti qui a dit on va pas
donner de chèque en blanc pour lui créer
le leader de la minorité à la Chambre
des représentés démocrates et pour la
République c'est ce que je voulais dire
il pourrait prendre la place de
l'Antiquité
il a dit on va pas donner de chèque en
blanc ce soir j'ai écouté l'une de ces
interventions qui datait de ce matin oui
il dit mais précisément qu'est-ce que
vous vous proposer qu'est-ce que vous
avez fait ce que vous allez retirer
votre soutien il a été extrêmement
évasif et bien évidemment il a expliqué
que des gens en 2014 il était déjà pro
ukrainien alors on y reviendra on aura
un vrai chapitre consacré aux
conséquences de ce scrutin sur l'aide à
l'Ukraine mais je voudrais vous proposer
un tout de suite un sondage qui est
celui du du site de référence pour les
élections américaines five 82 % des
chances de chances de remporter la
Chambre des représentants pour les
républicains et 54% de chances de
remporter le
Sénat avant de vous redonner la parole
je propose à Steve Jourdain qui doit
être juste derrière le le rideau en
coulisses de nous rejoindre re voilà
Steve parce que il y a on a commencé à
l'évoquer avec Jean-Claude Vaujour les
enjeux idéologiques mais il y a aussi
tous les enjeux institutionnels et on va
un peu rentrer dans le détail Joe Biden
pourra-t-il encore faire passer des lois
voilà très simplement très
schématiquement l'enjeu pour les
démocrates aux États-Unis le contrôle
des deux organes des deux organes du
Parlement est essentiel pour faire des
réformes actuellement la chambre des
temps en temps et le Sénat sont
contrôlés par les démocrates à la
Chambre des Représentants et démocrates
possèdent 220 sièges contre 212 pour les
républicains au Sénat chaque partie
détient 50 sièges la majorité démocrate
ne tient que grâce au sang une ième vote
de la vie présidente kamalahari suivi
présidente démocrate qui préside la
chambre de Thomas et alors comment
fonctionne ce scrutin des mythers
élections de mimanda alors les
Américains votent pour renouveler
l'ensemble de la Chambre des
Représentants soit 435 sièges et 435
sièges siège rond pendant deux ans et au
Sénat qui compte donc sans siège 35
mandats seulement sont remis en jeu ce
qui seront élus siègeront pendant 6 ans
à la Chambre haute sur ces 35 mandats 14
sont démocrates 21 sont républicain la
compétition s'annonce très serrée
plusieurs états seront comme d'habitude
ce côté à la loupe ce sont les fameux
swing set les états pivotent et alors en
cas de victoire des républicains Joe
Biden sera-t-il complètement paralysé
jusqu'à la fin de son mandat on va
commencer par le Sénat si les
républicains l'emportent ils
récupèreront un pouvoir très important
celui de confirmer ou non la nomination
des juges fédéraux on peut voir un
pouvoir qui s'étend jusqu'à jusqu'au
nomination à la Cour suprême si Joe
Biden veut nommer un juge qui ne plaît
pas aurait Puica ces derniers pourront
tout simplement bloquer cette nomination
la Chambre des Représentants elle a un
rôle qu'on comprend plus facilement nos
Français avec le Sénat elle vote les
lois fédérales et notamment le budget
une procédure sur laquelle le président
n'a pas la main et si les républicains
deviennent majoritaires au Congrès
demain ils ont annoncé qu'il serait
intraitable en matière de dépenses
publiques on pense au budget de la santé
et des retraites mais aussi à l'aide
financière à accorder à l'Ukraine 60
milliards de dollars ont déjà été
débloqués depuis le début de la guerre
en février certains républicains
dénoncent une politique du chèque en
blanc et compte bien revenir sur cette
aide ce dont on parlait à l'instant
autre enjeu important celui de
l'élection des gouverneurs oui les
Américains votent pour leur
représentants au Congrès mais ils
élisent aussi des représentants au
niveau local notamment les gouverneurs
ça sera le cas dans 36 États et là
encore ce scrutin sera décisif car les
gouverneurs ont des pouvoirs importants
par exemple en matière législative
l'avenir par exemple du droit à
l'avortement dans certains états
dépendra en bande partie de l'issue de
ce scrutin des gouverneurs Thomas merci
Steve Sylvie Berman il y a une
expression américaine je crois que c'est
le LaM Duck ça veut dire canard boiteux
j'en parlais dans dans les titres c'est
pas la première fois qu'un président
américain perdrait la majorité à
mi-mandat mais est-ce que ça arrive
souvent quand c'est le premier mandat
d'un président alors c'est très fréquent
effectivement que qu'il perd de les
mitter mais pourquoi
Joe Biden est un canard boiteux parce
qu'il a 80 ans qu'il aurait 82 ans si il
était réélu et 86 à la fin de son mandat
on voit bien que il a quand même un
certain nombre de de problèmes il paraît
assez frais les plus il a des problèmes
cognitifs assez assez bien connu et je
pense que c'est ça ça faiblesse autant
bon bien sûr parce que il aura une
chambre et peut-être un sénat style et
qu'effectivement pour les réformes pour
le vote du budget c'est beaucoup plus
dit beaucoup plus difficile pour lui
est-ce que cette campagne elle aura pas
souligner comme comme vous venez de le
dire l'incroyable faiblesse du coin
démocrate et de l'exécutif en
particulier avec un Obama appelé à la
rescousse pour animer les meetings on
l'a vu qu'il le fait c'est toujours un
plaisir de le voir parce que
dans un instant d'ailleurs mais un
jobiden
quasi fantôme et une caméra à risque qui
est passée où elle est passée où qu'elle
arrive
pour commencer c'est effectivement une
question qu'on peut se poser mais je
crois qu'elle d'une certaine manière
elle n'est pas nouvelle puisque ça
relève aussi de la façon dont Biden a
été élu il y a deux ans très limite on
sait que par exemple l'un des États où
ce où il y a une bataille là sur le fil
cliffhanger qui est la Géorgie
c'est l'état dans lequel il y a eu des
comptages et recontacent et recontacent
de voix ou démocrate et républicains
étaient vraiment à couteau tirés donc
Biden certes a été élu président mais on
sait dans quel dans quelles conditions
je ne reviens pas mais je pense que
c'est intéressant d'y revenir plus tard
sur le la fameuse attaque du Capitole du
6 janvier donc il y a vraiment un
phénomène nouveau dans cette élection
enfin qui se produit déjà depuis deux
ans mais là qui va apparaître sans doute
demain c'est ce qu'on appelle le dinar
un certain nombre de de candidats donc
principalement républicains qui se
disent que de toute façon on ne
reconnaîtra pas le résultat d'élection
demain donc sa place tous les candidats
dans une situation quand même
extrêmement difficile périlleuse on
parle de négationniste du scrutin sur le
traduit quoi un autre phénomène qui joue
contre Biden au-delà de en plus de son
âge c'est sur abondant c'est le fait que
son challenger eux n'a jamais reconnu la
défaite et qu'il reste en embuscade
c'est-à-dire qu'on on joue finalement la
partition précédente avec une pubnacité
et l'avantage c'est que l'ancien
président n'est pas président donc il
n'est pas aux affaires quand on est dans
l'opposition on peut critiquer à volonté
alors qu'il y a un binden qui tente qui
tente d'exister un deuxième élément pour
kamalaris précisément Biden est un homme
politique redoutable redouté et
expérimenté il avait qu'à malaris pour
gagner l'élection la seule chose c'est
que alors que tout le monde se disait
bon bah papy va rester à la maison et
Kamala Harris va faire le job elle ira
dans les sommets internationaux etc lui
ne l'a pas entendu comme cela et elle
est un peu éclipsée de ce que je sais un
peu
c'est lui qui a étouffé mais ils ne
s'empresse pas de de pousser de mettre
en avant sa vice-présidente c'est une
erreur alors peut-être on peut
comprendre Joe Biden qui qui imagine ce
représentait mais c'est quand même une
erreur majeure du Parti démocrate ça
c'est pas laisser comme la Harris je
crois prendre de la place médiatiquement
en
CV presque parfait
tout le monde a considéré que en fait
elle était en dessous de de sa
réputation et ça c'est arrivé très vite
comme
oui
et en dehors des États-Unis
qui n'a pas qui n'est pas dans cette
relation quasi fusionnelle j'ai envie de
dire qui avait par exemple Clinton et
algor même si ce sont un peu brouillés à
la fin
Obama était vraiment confiant avec Biden
c'est autre chose alors que le problème
c'est qu'on a tout de suite opposé et ça
ça existe les hommes politiques on a
tout de suite opposé le président des
services présidents de dire lui il était
là pour pouvoir gagner le siège et en
fait il fallait qu'il chauffe la place
pour lui et ça a peut-être monté monter
les équipes alors vous parliez de la
faiblesse c'est ce dont on évoque là
depuis quelques minutes de du Parti
démocrate et c'est vrai que elle
apparaît d'autant plus quand on écoute
Barack Obama prendre la parole et alors
là c'était samedi il est avec Joe Biden
dans un de ses swing state dont on parle
un état clé en Pennsylvanie
je comprends que la démocratie puisse ne
pas sembler être une priorité absolue en
ce moment sur tout lorsque vous vous
inquiétez de comment vous allez payer
vos factures mais lorsque la vraie
démocratie disparaît nous l'avons vu au
cours de l'histoire nous l'avons vu dans
le monde entier lorsque la vraie
démocratie disparaît
les gens sont blessés cela des
conséquences réelles ce n'est pas une
abstraction
les gouvernements commencent à vous dire
quels livres vous pouvez lire et
lesquels vous ne pouvez pas lire les
dissidents commencent à être enfermés
les journalistes commencent à être
enfermés s'ils ne suivent pas la ligne
du parti
est-ce que la démocratie américaine est
vraiment en danger puisque c'est l'axe
c'est l'angle de Barack Obama et d'une
manière générale de la campagne
démocrate dans cette émission discours
que vous n'êtes pas passé puisque il y a
un élément qui a été coupé là-haut au
montage Barack Obama dans la même
intervention dit la démocratie c'est un
sport d'équipe donc évidemment c'est une
attaque directe à Donald Trump qui qui
ramène toute à lui qui est cette
personnalité moi bien sûr que
surdimensionné que tout le monde commet
et connaît et donc là
Obama évidemment mais en avant la
nécessité absolue d'essayer de pouvoir
en tout cas essayer de sortir des
polarités absolument dramatiques aux
États-Unis qu'on ne connaît mais
d'ailleurs pas qu'aux États-Unis et de
remettre et de remettre sur le devant de
la scène la collectivité de la chambre
où doivent avoir lieu des débats et bien
sûr du Sénat donc c'est vraiment je
crois que c'est c'est un passage là
au-delà de ce qui vient d'être montré
qui est-ce que vous êtes
[Musique]
gagner cette élection donc il s'est
opposé à Trump dès 2020 là il prend ses
distances des scintilles sans Floride
prend aussi semble marquer ses distances
descentis ce qui n'est pas un enfant de
coeur d'ailleurs qui lui-même
extrêmement gouvernement
parce que j'essaye de pardon voilà
d'être le plus pédagogue possible parce
qu'il y a les gouverneurs à côté il y a
le Sénat de l'autre c'est pas c'est ce
sont pas les mêmes que surtout qui
potentiellement candidats
juste après mais pourquoi l'élection des
gouverneurs c'est c'est extrêmement
important
j'ai envie de dire pour deux ou trois
raisons la première c'est que n'oublions
pas que ce sont les gouverneurs qui
certifient les votes lors du scrutin
présidentiel et on se souvient que le
président le président Trump avait fait
pression pour qu'un certain nombre de
gouverneurs dont celui de la Géorgie
fasse leur job d'ailleurs cet été sur
dans un certain nombre d'États les alors
secrétaire d'État de l'État c'est une
sorte de je sais pas comment traduire
une sorte de de président de conseil
général améliorer quelque chose un peu
comme ça en charge les élections il y a
une grosse effort de fait justement pour
dire on met tout en place pour que le
scrutin les scrutés à venir se déroulent
correctement parce que ça c'était une
préoccupation donc oui les gouverneurs
ont cette importance et puis les
gouverneurs vont faire campagne donc et
ce sont des états on parlait de la
Géorgie on parlait de la Pennsylvanie on
parlait de l'Arizona ce sont des états
que binden a gagné lors de la dernière
élection présidentielle ce sont des
états clés parce qu'ils apportent
énormément de sièges comme grands
électeurs beaucoup de grands électeurs
donc pour la dynamique présidentielle il
est important si les républicains
remportaient de nouveau ces états c'est
vrai que ça créerait des vents des vents
derrière qui pousseraient
automatiquement donc pour cette raison
les sur le plan législatif enfin les
gouverneurs ont leur importance et on
sait que si oppose républicain et
démocrate aujourd'hui on est sur des
fondamentaux on est pour ou contre le
doigt à l'avortement pour certains
nombre de de droits notamment et on sait
que jusqu'à estomac veut revenir sur le
doigt des homosexuels donc on est sur de
la doctrine des oppositions relativement
fortes de la part des républicains les
plus à droite parce que vous avez des
républicains modéré donc voilà un petit
peu pour toutes ces raisons
l'élection de de du gouverneur des
gouverneurs à son importance pour le
Mathieu qui a une partie des
républicains qui est vaccinée quand même
contre Donald Trump surtout après
l'événement du Capitole et ils vont pas
tous partir comme un seul homme derrière
lui si jamais il faut gagner l’élection
ça crée une forme de légitimité que vous
ne vouliez ou non nous sommes justement
si on va jusqu'au bout de la réflexion
nous sommes en démocratie à partir du
moment où celui qui est candidat gagne
l'élection ou en tout cas
potentiellement la gagner ben ça crée un
appel d'air d'ailleurs Donald Trump ne
s'y est pas trompé à cause de ces
affaires judiciaires il a tout intérêt à
jouer cette carte là parce que ça
pourrait neutraliser une partie de
l'activité d'ailleurs si lui Berman je
peut-être que c'est un prisme français
mais l'impression qu'on a nous d'ici
c'est que c'est Donald Trump qui fait
campagne alors évidemment c'est beaucoup
plus compliqué que ça mais celui qui va
tirer profit d'une éventuelle victoire
des républicains demain ce sera Donald
Trump oui clairement mais de toute façon
il est déjà en campagne électorale pour
de nombreuses
l'occasion d'un comme une banque contre
et oui mais il continue de dominer le
parti puisque en fait une grande
majorité des républicains considèrent
que l'élection a été volée c'est-à-dire
qu'il reprenne les les thèses de Trump
en plus il a éliminé ce qui lui était
hostile et donc il est bien parti là on
sait pas ce qui peut se passer pendant
les deux ans mais effectivement pour
l'emporter vous parliez d'âge il aura 78
ans
pour les prochaines élections
je reviens sur ce cette démocratie
américaine même si j'ai bien entendu que
vous vouliez être prudente là-dessus
mais quand même c'est très clairement un
axe de de campagne alors c'est
intéressant parce que il y a
effectivement les candidats ou les
candidates du parti républicain qui sont
très clairement sur la ligne Trump par
exemple car il est quelle est candidate
au poste de gouverneur de l'Arizona on
lui demande qu'est-ce qui se passe si
vous perdez l'élection est-ce que vous
allez reconnaître votre défaite regardez
ma question est allez-vous accepter le
résultat de votre élection en novembre
je vais gagner cette élection et je vais
accepter ce résultat et si vous perdez
vous l'accepterez je vais gagner cette
élection et je vais accepter ce résultat
ça peut durer pour de longues minutes
parce qu'elle répondra toujours la même
chose à la question je le disais tout à
l'heure Joe Biden appelle ses
républicains moi je dis mauvais perdant
potentiellement les négationnistes de
l'élection on écoute le président
américain
c'est négationniste de l'élection
n'essaye pas seulement de nier votre
droit de vote ils essayent de nier votre
droit à ce que votre vote soit compté
non je ne plaisante pas je ne plaisante
pas avec ces négationnistes des
élections il n'y a que deux issues soit
il gagne soit ils ont été trompés je
suis sérieux pensez-y et laissez-moi
vous dire quelque chose vous ne pouvez
pas aimer le pays seulement quand vous
gagnez
on espère que c'est une parenthèse dans
l'histoire américaine évidemment ce
qu'on est en train de de vivre mais
fondamentalement c'est c'est la base les
piliers d'une démocratie qui sont remis
en cause par ce type de comportement
quand on perd une élection on dit
qu'elle a été truquée ça n'en finit
jamais oui vous avez montré car en
Arizona et c'est tout à fait l'exemple
de Dina voilà quelqu'un qui ne
reconnaîtra pas si elle est battue le
fait qu'elle soit battues je pense qu'il
y a aussi pardon je vous souhaite
l'autorité de celui qui l'a emporté
enfin c'est l'objectif il est d'abord là
c'est arrive sur le devant de la scène
tout une série d'éléments techniques
dont on parlait très très peu dans les
élections précédentes et maintenant
comme il y a énormément de de votre par
correspondance qui s'est développé aussi
grâce ou à cause du covid il faut il
faut bien le il faut bien le reconnaître
il y a aussi matière à plus
d'irrégularités donc il se trouve en au
moment où on parle en Pennsylvanie qui
est aussi un état pivot un état là qui
qui est sur le point de basculer d'un
côté ou de l'autre il semble qu'un
certain nombre de butin de vote ne
seront pas stabiliser parce que donc il
y a déjà des procédures en cours au
moment où je parle donc on en trouve un
petit peu de scénario qui s'était
produit qui s'était produit à deux ans
donc ça évidemment si ce phénomène se
reproduit à chaque élection évidemment
ça fragilise la nature même de
l'élection oui mais là encore c'est vrai
partout je suis avocat je peux vous dire
qu'après chaque élection y compris en
France vous avez une série de recours il
conseille des tels qui me
l'administratif ce ce prononce contre
ses recours ce qui a du dramatique et je
pense qu'au de la même du mode de ce
côté est-ce qu'il y a de dramatique et
je crains pour répondre à votre question
vous avez dit est-ce que c'est une
parenthèse moi je ne pense pas je pense
que nous vivons une période particulière
ou la croyance que l'on a
est supérieur au fait c'est à dire que
quoi que vous expliquiez parce que dans
un scrutin par exemple ce que fait un
président de bureau de vote il regarde
le nombre de bureaux de bulletins qui
sont irréguliers et ils regardent si le
scrutin serait éventuellement modifié si
les choses se seraient donc ça c'est
vrai mais la croyance est-elle et
aujourd'hui ce qui est de plus important
c'est que les gens imaginent ont une
croyance et peu importe ce que vous
pouvez dire et preuve que c'est ça n'est
pas une parenthèse il y a un sondage
récent qui indique que ton chéri
républicain que j'ai démocrate les
acteurs sont désormais
favorables à voter pour le candidat de
leur partie même si celui-ci présentait
un défaut de moralité sur les valeurs
sur les valeurs même si celui-ci était
défaillant sur sur les valeurs
personnelles qui ne sont prises sont
propres vous rendez compte c'est à dire
que peu importe celui qui est en face ou
peu importe que celui qu'on vous propose
dans votre camp vous votez pour lui la
messe est dite si Berman lui intervenir
peut-être sur la solidité de la
démocratie américaine parce que vous
avez pas vous l'avez pas évoqué tout à
l'heure absolument quand j'étais à la
Mission permanente à New York auprès des
Nations Unies madeleines old bright
était la représentante permanente
américaine elle est devenue la
secrétaire d'État de Bill Clinton et
elle expliquait à ce moment-là aux Afric
chez qui l'ONU organisé des élections
que la définition de la démocratie
c'était de reconnaître quand on avait
perdu une élection et de préparer la
suivante et tout ça ne manque pas de sel
aujourd'hui ou ce sont les Américains
eux-mêmes qui ne respectent pas le
résultat des élections et on imagine pas
le mal que ça fait dans le monde à la
démocratie de manière générale sur aux
États-Unis bien sûr qui a perdu de son
aura mais de manière générale au système
démocratique et beaucoup de pays disent
aujourd'hui vous n'avez pas de leçon à
nous donner mais pardon est-ce que les
mesures ont été prises depuis le dernier
vote parce que je sais qu'on a contesté
vous souvenez les machines à voter on a
contesté la réclaré de votre parcours
est-ce que les démocrates ont dit
je viens de je suis pas spécialiste du
processus électoral en tant que tel je
peux vous dire que tout cet été il y
avait des débats dans un cercle nombre
d'États on revenait sur le mode de
scrutin vérifiez que le mode de scrutin
soit plus sûr etc en sachant qu'il y a
toujours une limite parce qu'il y a des
questions de majorité pour pouvoir
modifier un mode de scooter et
démocratie républicains tous deux le
responsabilité de ce point de vue mais
moi je pense que la démocratie en tant
que telle n'est pas menacé parce que les
institutions vont continuer à
fonctionner et il y a suffisamment
d'Américains des gens si les gens qui ne
parlent pas qui sont aujourd'hui
s'envoient sont des gens qui ont des
intérêts il y a de grandes entreprises
vous avez un centre de leader d'opinion
de grandes voies américaines qui
s'exprimeront le moment venu et je pense
que les institutions
tiendront en revanche la fracturation de
de la société américaine et plus forte
que jamais elle va se renforcer
un problème qui qui est qui remonte à
beaucoup plus longtemps qui est la
question de la participation électorale
et aux États-Unis elle est faible
beaucoup plus faible qu'elle n'est par
exemple en France depuis des décennies
donc la question
de la participation qui devrait être
améliorée grâce
au vote par correspondance se trouve là
en but à tous ces contestations elle
n'est que de 60% elle n'est que de 60
millions à la présidentielle face à nos
80 je crois que l'année où Sarkozy était
comme ça c'était 80 2% oui alors qu'on
l'a vu ça a baissé beaucoup depuis mais
alors qu'on l'a dit les Américains quand
ils vont aller voter demain ils votent
pour X scrutin en même temps quoi donc
on concentre tout en une seule journée
donc ça pourrait ça pourrait provoquer
une participation plus importante on
pourrait l'imaginer je voudrais qu'on
revienne sur la question du du pouvoir
d'achat et puis ça va nous ouvrir
évidemment un nouveau chapitre dans ce
débat consacré à l'Ukraine et à aux
conséquences de ces élections de
mi-mandat sur l'aide donné par les
Américains ou
Ukrainiens une réaction pour commencer
sur le pouvoir d'achat selle d'un
candidat républicain il le poste de
sénateur de Pennsylvanie
combien d'entre vous sont inquiets pour
l'Amérique en ce moment
vous allez à irriller vous entendez de
jeunes couples parler de leur incapacité
à rembourser le premier versement sur un
prêt parce que les taux d'intérêt sont
trop élevés
vous descendez à Pittsburg et même à
Pittsburgh il s'inquiète de ne plus
pouvoir souffrir des sorties en famille
je reviens vers vous Christine du vélo
parce que vous avez évoqué la question
du carburant est-ce que vous direz que
c'est même le modèle américain qui est
challenge enfin fragilisé par par cette
hausse des prix de l'énergie oui là il y
a j'ai envie de dire une collision entre
le modèle américain basé sur le
carburant la voiture félaire les
standard Dolls qui sont des mythes
constitutifs de des États-Unis de la
voiture et des questions aussi
climatiques donc les États-Unis sont un
peu à la traîne pour ne pas employer
d'autres mots sur cette question donc là
évidemment on a la conjonction de je
regardais ce matin le prix d'un galon de
d'essence aux États-Unis
suivant les états frôlent les quatre à
cinq dollars c'est ce qui est évidemment
aussi élevé que que des augmentations
que l'on a en Europe mais
l'essentialité de la voiture
du véhicule à moteur à essence aux
États-Unis et absolument incontournable
aujourd'hui donc là je crois que
évidemment ce que dit ose
qui par ailleurs
et dans une course très très
intéressante pour le Sénat en
Pennsylvanie contre un candidat
démocrate dont on pense que peut-être là
je rentre dans la fiction que je vais
éviter
il pourrait remporter le
poste de sénateur le Sénat Jean-Claude
baujour puis après on sera vraiment sur
le sur l'Ukraine absolument compte qu'en
fait on n'est pas on n'est pas allés sur
les enjeux du Sénat donc on va le faire
maintenant donc on l'a dit steam journal
disait tout à l'heure pour l'instant
c'est 55 ans c'est la la voie de la
vice-président qui pèse donc ça va ça va
se jouer sur quoi sur un ou deux
états
puisqu'on sait qu'il y a 35 sièges en
lice il y en a 21 22 qui pourraient être
qui sont quasiment à qui aurai
républicain environ 11 12 qui sont moi
qui aux démocrates donc c'est un de
siège en Géorgie et
je effectivement il y a il y a en
Pennsylvanie voilà il y a des tout va se
jouer dans un mouchoir de poche
d'ailleurs ça n'est pas innocent s'il
est les gros candidats en fait sont
allés là-bas sont allés là-bas en
Pennsylvanie en Géorgie ils sont allés
faire campagne là où il y a et puis en
Floride aussi Donald Trump a fait une
intervention en Floride bon allez comme
ça j'ai tenu la promesse on a parlé
aussi du Sénat le l'Ukraine avec un
sondage là aussi pour évaluer
l'acceptation par l'opinion américaine
des mesures d'aide à l'Ukraine depuis le
début de de cette guerre elle est
globalement acceptée par l'opinion
publique regardez sondage comment
considérez-vous le soutien américain à
l'Ukraine si on ajoute la réponse
adéquate à la réponse
pas assez élevée finalement on arrive à
une pas une majorité assez assez forte
il y a seulement 20% des des personnes
interrogées qui jugent que c'est trop
élevé Sylvie Berman comment on peut
imaginer les conséquences d'un d'une
victoire républicaine c'est quand même
ce qui se profile à l'horizon ou en tout
cas d'un Joe Biden fragilisé dans la
dans la seconde partie de son mandat
donc les conséquences de ce scrutin sur
l'aide américain à l'Ukraine comment
vous l'imaginez le soutien à l'Ukraine
est assez bi partisan comme on peut le
voir ici d'abord parce que dans la
période précédente déjà la Russie était
détestée puisque il y avait même eu un
procès en illégitimité de Trump à cause
des de l'ingérence russe donc je pense
que là démocrate et républicain se
retrouve mais comme on va rentrer
finalement pratiquement en campagne pour
les élections de 2024 ce qui va être
utilisé c'est le fils de Joe Biden W qui
avait des Hunter je crois qui a été dans
je sais pas si présidé pas même un
conseil de de surveillance ou de
coordination d'une entreprise gazière
ukrainienne donc je pense que ça ça va
entrer dans la dans la campagne et ce
qui a été dit par ma cartey donc il
pourrait remplacer comment le dit tout à
l'heure dans six palosie c'est que en
tout cas ça ne devrait pas être un
chèque en blanc ça veut pas dire qu'il y
aura pas d'aide on peut la voir
s'afficher cette cette citation je sais
comment
vous nous parlez on va voir la citation
de Kevin McCarthy je pense que les
Américains vont bientôt se retrouver
dans une récession il ne voudront pas
écrire un chèque en blanc pour l'Ukraine
ce n'est pas possible comment vous
analysez cette phrase
vous avez un parti républicain qui se
préoccupe ou en tout cas qui intervient
sur la base des difficultés économiques
des Américains ce que je disais tout à
l'heure c'est que pour eux c'est America
Feurs il faut aider les Américains avant
d'aider les Ukrainiens c'est en ce
sens-là que ça peut effectivement jouer
mais Jean-Claude baujour cette aide
américaine elle fait aussi tourner des
usines américaines il faut pas l'oublier
sur les 60 milliards de dollars il y a à
peu près pour pour
50% d'aide militaires en matériel
militaire donc ça fait vivre
l'industrie de l'armement américaine
voilà donc très concrètement je vois mal
les républicains qui ont quand même dans
leur camp puisque ce sont ceux-là aussi
qui financés campagnes et surtout s'il y
a une dynamique qui leur est favorable
donc ils vont avoir des tas
d'entreprises qui sont derrière eux je
les vois mal dire aux entreprises
bénéficiaire de cette aide là bon ben on
va vous couper donc je pense qu'il
s'agit d'une déclaration de campagne
elle est restée floue tout est très
approximatif et que tout ça ça va se
jouer au cas par cas d'ailleurs comme je
pense que il est allé à bonne école
puisque en général Donald Trump vous dit
oui mais il trouve toujours une parade
que vous expliquer qu'il a l'islam et
qu'effectivement là il a regardé très
près que il faut revoir les choses c'est
c'est je veux pas être mon cœur mais
c'est un petit peu cela donc il
trouveront le moyen de revenir mais il
ne peuvent pas comme cela de but en
blanc dire on ne donne pas d'aide non
parce que ça profite aussi à l'économie
américaine et puis ça redonne du tonus à
aux États-Unis sur la sphère
internationale ça permet aussi d'avoir
je parle s'autorité de Madame Berman un
certain nombre de contreparties on est
de l'Ukraine parce que si on n'est pas
l'Ukraine les européens bénéficient
aussi un peu parce que sinon on serait
seul à faire le job contre partie les
Américains obtiennent aussi un certain
nombre de d'éléments donc tout ça ça je
ne suis pas inquiet il ne me semble pas
qu'il y aura un revirement complet de la
politique américaine en Ukraine vous
parliez des conséquences judiciaires de
ce scrutin on va terminer là-dessus
Christine zoello il y a il y a la
question des procédures qui visent
Donald Trump il y en a plusieurs et
notamment vous y avez fait allusion tout
à l'heure la commission d'enquête sur
l'assaut donnée au Capitole est-ce qu'on
sait déjà ce que les ce que les
républicains ont prévu si l'emporte en
la matière donc ça c'est aussi une
question importante cette commission est
constituée de neuf neuf personnes il y a
7 démocrates et deux républicains dont
listiani la fille du
Dick Jenny et
donc le fait qu'elle soit majorité
démocrate
rend difficile
l'abolition de cette commission si les
républicains prenaient le contrôle de la
Chambre ça ça paraît difficile mais en
revanche il risque effectivement d'y
avoir un certain nombre de de pression
de difficultés pour qu'elles puissent
mener son travail à bien d'ailleurs la
la résidence de Donald Trump en Floride
a été perquisitionné à grand fracas dans
les dans les journaux et dans la presse
et dans les médias au début de l'automne
et la question que se pose cette
commission aujourd'hui c'est de savoir
si Trump lui-même peut être amené à
comparer je sais pas si c'est le terme
qu'on utiliserait en français mais à
comparer devant cette commission pour
témoigner en tout cas mais ça veut dire
vous pensez que les républicains
pourraient pas totalement stopper la
procédure elle est trop avancée c'est ça
ça dépend de la personne qui sera nommée
qui serait nommée à la place de Nancy
Pelosi si les républicains prennent la
direction de la chance tout dépend de ce
que pourrait dire le département justice
le voilà il y a quand même une autre
parce que ça n'est pas une de une
commission judiciaire au sens juridique
du terme donc c'est une commission entre
guillemets c'est comme une commission
d'enquête
parlementaire donc elle a elle peut
faire des recommandations elle peut
gérer des conclusions mais il y a des
procédures pénales qui devront être
initié ou pas donc après et là encore le
temps judiciaire n'est pas le temps
politique je pense que nous n'avons pas
le temps d'avoir des résultats de procès
et si Donald Trump joue bien vous savez
dans un an même qu'il déclare ou pas
qu'il soit candidats mais les choses
viennois maturité d'ici un an et d'ici
non on je vois mal le pouvoir judiciaire
aller à vraiment à bouler tirer tirer à
boulet rouge sur quelqu'un qui serait un
candidat de premier plan ça ne ferait là
pour le coup ça ne ferait qu'à graver ce
sentiment de de d'acharnement et puis
même d'éclatement de la société
américaine s'il était en pleine campagne
avec une dynamique pour lui et que des
procédures venaient à contrecarrer sa
campagne là vous auriez là là on serait
de mon point de vue mais ça n'est que
pour le coup que de la queue de la
fiction
parallèle qui est établie de plus en
plus entre cette commission et la
commission d'enquête sur Watergate qui
avait donné lieu à un rapport du Sénat
passionnant à lire d'ailleurs en 73
venait d'être élu c'était tout c'est
voilà et puis ce qui est frappant
évidemment c'est que des procédures
visant Donald Trump il y en a eu
d'autres finalement plusieurs il y en a
eu pendant ce sa présidence on a
l'impression qu'elle glisse on parlait
du canard boiteux là c'est ça glisse sur
les ailes du canard quoi oui tout à fait
et je pense alors bon je suis moins
spécialiste que vous sur les questions
judiciaires américaines mais je pense
que à partir du moment effectivement il
rentrera vraiment dans la phase de
candidature et encore une fois tout le
monde considère que son activisme
aujourd'hui prépare cette phase là et
s'il y a une victoire des républicains
je pense que ça sera plus ou moins
abandonné ou en tout cas ça traînera en
longueur vous allez poser une il faut
qu'il passe par là de toute façon par la
case des primaires bien sûr
pas encore gagné il a pas déjà gagné les
primaires
moins favorable aujourd'hui mais à voir
je reste sur ma prudence qu'il y a qu'il
y a deux ans donc la case des primaires
est très importante de Santis et kemps
les deux candidats
sont en embuscade vous avez posé une
question en disant mais Donald Trump qui
a des tas de procédures je vais vous
dire on parlait tout à l'heure de nos
jeunes années aux États-Unis moi j'étais
adolescent lorsqu'il y avait déjà des
scandales contre Donald Trump Atlantic
City des trucs dans l'immobilier j'ai
des copains qui me disaient mais il est
fréquentable etc et pourtant il est
toujours là il a été président des
États-Unis vous voyez donc oui mais
c'est ce que je disais c'est en fait ça
ne ça ne fera pas particulier alors
c'est sa personnalité c'est sa capacité
à balayer les accusations voilà à coups
de fake news et puis c'est aussi ce
qu'on disait tout à l'heure c'est c'est
partisans qui sont dans leur dans leur
bulle de vérité dans leur Bull cognitive
et qui finalement ne tiennent pas compte
de absolument absolument mais bien
construit
alors qu'il est le pur produit de les
établissement mais il s'est construit
anti-establishment il s'est construit
d'ailleurs c'est cela ils disent on
voyait la cieux il y avait des photos il
y a une type dans les dans les dans les
différentes réunions qu'il a organisé je
suis pour les armes je mange de la
viande
bisser l'Amérique profonde moyenne
l'Amérique profonde il le revendiquent
et au fond un électeur que vous soyez
lecteur à New York ou bien électeurs
dans le vice consigne deux acteurs
comptent plus que peu un et puis c'est
ce qu'on sait ce qu'on oublie peut-être
mais ça plaît ça continue de plaire aux
Américains merci beaucoup à tous d'avoir
participé à ce débat Sylvie Berman je
vais rappeler le titre de votre livre
évidemment madame l'ambassadeur c'est
publié aux éditions talents dit on dit
pas Madame l'ambassadrice
on peut dire Madame l'ambassadrice mais
dans ma génération moi je tiens
ambassadeur disons il y a plus de 20 ans
déjà et donc à l'époque on confondait
avec la femme de l'ambassadeur donc
je préférais ce titre qui était plus
clair on a bien compris merci beaucoup
c'est donc c'est aux éditions talandiers
merci encore à toute à toutes et à tous
merci Matthieu on se retrouve mercredi
ce sera vous et ben avec grand plaisir à
demain 18h 22h sur public Senna et puis
l'invité de bonjour chez vous c'est Marc
féno le ministre de l'Agriculture il
sera 8h et il sera face à Oriane Mancini
[Musique]